past it can we quickly go backtrack what  the intergalactic bus stop yeah should  we should we know more about this is  there something  so i was reaching out to everybody i  could trying to get hold of the arizona  department of transportation for a  little bit more on that i-15 bridge  project and i'm looking around the  google map and there's the  intercollected bus stop and there's a  phone number and i call chris and he  goes  yeah it's not just humans anybody can  stop here  let me give you a heads up there's no  buildings there oh it's just a patch of  dirt  okay i will not be stopping  but there's a bunch of stuff in the  neighborhood it's definitely worth  checking out and  if you meet chris i want to know more  about him